[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hermione granger
professor simple trolloni and the
subject of divination
more specifically we're going to be
addressing why it is that hermione
seemingly hates divination so much
divination is taught at hogwarts by
professor cybil trelawny
it's an elective course taught from
third year onwards
divination is essentially the art of
predicting the future
there are various ways to achieve this
these methods include
but are not limited to tea leaves fire
omens
crystal balls palmistry cartomancy
astrology and dream interpretations many
witches and wizards
talented though they are in the area of
loud bangs and smells and sudden
disappearings
are yet unable to penetrate the veiled
mysteries of the future
though divination is a legitimate
subject and area of magic
it is often the target of considerable
scrutiny students
witches wizards and even other
professors seemingly constantly question
its legitimacy and was once described by
mcgonagall as
one of the most imprecise branches of
magic even dumbledore has his qualms
with the subject
and certainly didn't embrace it as part
of hogwarts curriculum
on a cold wet night 16 years ago in a
room above the bar at the hog's head in
i had gone there to see an applicant for
the post of divination teacher
though it was against my inclination to
allow the subject of divination
to continue at all the applicant however
was the great great granddaughter of a
very famous
very gifted seer and i thought it common
politeness to meet her
i was disappointed it seemed to me that
she had not a trace of the gift herself
i told her courteously i hope that i did
not think she would be suitable for the
post
i turned to leave but of course just as
he left
sibyl trolloni foretold the prophecy the
same prophecy that would flip the
wizarding world
upside down but when hermione first sets
foot in professor sybil troll on his
class
she's really not impressed and outwardly
disrespects her new professor
right at the very beginning the falcon
my dear
you have a deadly enemy but everyone
knows that
said hermione in a loud whisper
professor trollony stared at her
well they do said hermione everybody
knows about harry and you know who
harry and ron stared at her with a
mixture of amazement and admiration
they had never heard hermione speak to a
teacher like that before
so what's the deal why is hermione so
unimpressed with divination
and her new professor sure trelawny
doesn't have a flawless track
record but predicting something like the
prophecy
has got to account for something well
first of all tronny didn't get off to a
great start with hermione
when she discredited the use of books in
the subject everyone knows you can't
discredit books
in front of hermione books can only take
you so far in this field
at these words both harry and ron
glanced grinning at hermione
who looked startled at the news that
books wouldn't be much help in this
subject
next hermione was a huge proponent of
arithmancy which is almost a
contradictory subject
arathmensi is a branch of magic
concerned with the magical properties of
numbers
and it's hermione's favorite arithmancy
is all about calculating
tangible things which differs from
divination which has more of an
ethereal component to it arithmancy is
about logic
and numbers and divination is about
feeling and premonition
are you starting to see why she didn't
like it it also didn't help hermione's
opinion of the subject that most of the
other professors
openly disrespected it this likely
cemented her attitude toward it
right from the very beginning next
hermione was all about good grades
and it's hard to do well in a subject
when there's no right or wrong
hermione is not the type of person that
likes to fuss about she likes to
solidify concepts and ideas
and has no patience for anything this is
unable to meet this criteria
in order to do well in true on his class
you have to embrace your inner mystic
and this is just not something that
hermione would put up with
this is why she eventually drops the
class altogether
and that's why hermione hates the
subject of divination
but given trollony's track record you
know predicting the prophecy
do you think she deserves more credit is
it fair that divination is scrutinized
so much let us know down in the comment
section below
until next time you're a wizard harry